- Why am I nervous?
(gentle piano music)
- It feels weird calling right now,
I'm a little nervous.
(laughs)
- He's probably going to be very confused.
(phone ringing)
I just wanted to call
and tell you something.
- [Woman's father] What
were you gonna tell me?
You're married?
- No! (laughs)
I just wanted to call
and tell you I love you.
- [Woman's father] That's very
nice of you, I appreciate it.
I'm glad you love me 'cause
that's very important to me.
- Aw.
- Hi, dad!
- Hey, Liz!
- How are you?
- I'm good. How are you?
- I'm good, I just wanted to call
and say that I love you and I miss you.
- (laughs) I love you, too.
- I just wanted to call and
tell you that I love you.
- [Woman's father] Oh,
that's nice! (woman laughs)
I'll take that.
- I'll take that?! (laughs)
Why do you think dads have a
hard time saying I love you?
- [Woman's father] Oh, I, it's just...
I don't understand, you guys make it...
You guys have it so easy and
you can say that so easily.
I don't know.
It's 'cause it's some kind
of defect in our jaws.
- In the jaw?
- [Woman's father] Yeah, it's in our jaws.
- Oh my god, that's
bullshit. (woman laughs)
- [Woman's Father] Well, I,
okay. Well, I love you too.
And--
- I'll take that.
- [Woman's Father] And that's
really sweet of you to call.
It's an unexpected delight.
- Hi!
- I just wanted to call you
and tell you that I love you.
- That's great!
Couple days early for
that, but that's fine.
- Do you love me, too?
- Love it.
I love you too!
- [Alec] I just wanted to
let you know that I love you.
- Aww!
And I love you too, Thank you Alec.
- I just wanted to call
and say that I love you.
- [Woman's Father] Aw, I love you too.
- How's your day going?
- [Woman's father] Very much.
- Aww!
- I just wanted to call
and say that I love you.
- Well, I love you too.
(laughing)
- Um, that's awesome. (laughing)
- Well, good.
- What do you want, now? (laughs)
- [Woman] But I'm just
calling to say, I love you!
- I love you too!
- [Woman] Bye!
- Bye have a great night!
- Because I don't have too
long, I just wanted to call
and tell you that I love you.
- Well, I love you too, man.
- Thanks pops, yeah.
That's it, that's all I wanted to say.
I just wanted to call and tell you that.
- You are an amazing young man.
- (laughing) Thanks, pops.
- Hey, I just wanted
to say that I love you.
- I love you too!
Why? Are you doing a video?
- (laughs) No! Hey, that's..
Just, that's it.
- Okay, what's going on?
- Nothing.
I'm just saying I love you.
Happy Almost-Father's Day!
- I love you! Thank you, Kendall.
- I got two dads, I got
a stepdad that raised me,
and also I got a biological dad.
I'm about to call my stepdad
because he's the one that raised me.
(laughing)
- Hola, papi. What you doing?
- I'm eating B.
Are you eating, B?
- I'm in a restaurant.
- Oh are ya?
- What's up?
I gotta tell you something.
- What is it?
I just called you to
tell you that I love you.
- Oh yeah? (laughing)
I love you too, Papi, I love you too.
That's good.
- No, I also want to say
that I appreciate everything
you've done for me.
You raised me well, you've
always been there for me,
and, you know, you always had my back.
- Stop it you're gonna
make me (beep) cry here.
What's wrong with you?
(laughs maniacally)
You're a (beep).
You know I love you too.
Everything is like clockwork.
- Yeah.
- Everything is the same.
You know I love you and
I'm very proud of you.
I'm very proud of everything you do too
and I'm proud of what
you have become as a man.
No matter what, our ups and downs.
You're just living proof
of that whatever we did
right or wrong, it came
out for the better,
because look how you are.
- You did your job, you did
a swell job in raising me.
- You're the man, you're
the man. (laughing)
Right. Alright, Papi, te quiero mucho.
- I love you man take it easy.
Thank you for calling
me, appreciate it, bye.
- Wow, uh. (laughs)
- [Man] That was beautiful, man.
How do you feel right now?
- I feel overwhelmed
(laughs) with emotions.
It feels good.
You don't hardly take time to,
I never took time to really sit down,
but thank you for everything
that you've done for me
and that you've given me.
The man that I am today
is because of this man.
You taught me, man.
He took me on.
He became a stepfather at
17-years-old, you know?
He didn't have to do none of that, so.
He raised me to be a man, to be tough,
to try to do his best,
to teach me everything
and I love him.
Yeah.
If it wasn't for him,
I would be in the streets
somewhere, so, that's that.
(gentle piano music)